foreign
as you know by now we have a new trailer
and a pretty big one at that very
exciting and I decided to do things a
bit differently than with the previous
teasers and just improvise my analysis
right there on the spot and record it in
one single take because the truth is I'm
pretty bad at recording voiceovers
quickly and I Stumble over my words a
lot which you will notice over the
course of this video as well and most of
what you're about to hear was recorded
last night right after I ended the live
stream so there will be some changes in
the way I speak and the pitch and
stamina of my voice you're gonna hear a
little bit more accent a bit more Angry
Dutch guy also I cut up and condense
some segments from last night because
they weren't really going anywhere or
I've changed my mind or found something
new I was finding out a lot of stuff
while I was doing the analysis so for
example at one point I say there's no
scripture like that new scripture that
we've seen there's none of it in this
teaser but then later I do see the
script and I will correct myself so
before you type a comment like no no
there is there is it's advised that you
you watch the whole thing first of
course your feedback is always welcome
so don't shy away from sharing details
but just know that sometimes I might
correct myself later on or I might
interject so with all that said I'm
gonna let tired Dawn from last night
take over from now first shot not much
to see here we do see like a lightning
strike which lights up one of the
islands but that's about it second shot
pretty interesting we can see one of
those spirals again which we also saw in
the second teaser I believe the third
one the third teaser had one on the on
the floor I think these might be like
the new travel points either that or
they're going to be connected to the
islands in the sky we see Death Mountain
with the malice we see more lightning
strikes yada yada there's not too much
to see here uh we finally see the flying
enemy a little bit better which we
caught a very brief glimpse of in the
previous teaser I'm not too sure if
these are recurring enemies or if it's
something new I remember are some people
I forgot the name of them they were in
Twilight Princess but uh yeah we see a
couple of them flying around we see I
think this is the training ground the
military training camp I should say uh
more lightning strikes a goblin nothing
too special okay yeah this one is pretty
interesting we can see one of those
drawings on the floor again which lights
up during the night which looks pretty
cool if there's going to be lots of them
that's going to be a beautiful sight to
see we see new towers which I think will
probably be this game's replacement of
the shika Towers there's four spotlights
surrounding them I don't know why maybe
so they stand out just like how the
sheikah Towers also glowed you need to
be able to easily see them from a
distance so I guess well four spotlights
does it does the job just fine I would
say I'm not too sure about the shape of
those Towers uh if you remember I made a
video about zonai Dragon Towers not too
sure if that's this
they look I don't know it's hard to see
they look like they have some sort of
horn-like structure at the at the top
um next shot
um oh wait no actually before we move to
the move on to the next one we do see
the first glimpse of the storm I think
this is the same storm that we see in
the in the in the key art in the the
artwork we received when the third
teaser came out and it's actually much
higher up in the sky I thought it was
more like on ground level and like
rising up all the way into the sky but
it seems like that's not the case it
seems like it's like hovering like above
the cloud layer this one I don't really
see too much yeah it's just a skyshell
we do see like one of those drawings
again or at least it seems like it's one
of those drawings like in the in the
corner and we see some sort of glowing
platform or maybe that's the Labyrinth
actually yeah I think that might be one
of the labyrinths the the north lome
Labyrinth the one in the water might be
that one I'm not 100 sure it's kind of
hard to see the detail sales next shot
oh yeah this is an interesting one
there's a lot to see here so obviously
the attention immediately goes to the to
the enemies we see what looks like
malice infused enemies especially the
the lizel foes looks like it has like
red glowing edges to it here in the
corner we see these ghostly flames and
I'm pretty sure if you've played
Twilight Princess these are gonna look
pretty familiar I don't know if it's the
exact same thing if like the highlands
have been turned into Spirits would be
very cool could even be maybe some sort
of connection to the Twilight realm
which I know a lot of people want and
it's a very popular thing like the zonai
are they the Twilight and all that kind
of stuff
in general this place looks very like if
you've seen stranger things like upside
down esque I would say uh it's very dark
the the vegetation is very weird there's
this weird like almost looks like it has
scales and like this bulb at the bottom
it looks very uh like otherworldly I'm
not too sure if this may be underground
because the sky is like all black I'm
not 100 sure but it could be could be
some sort of underground which by the
way we will get into soon because we do
have confirmation that there will be
caves and underground stuff uh no
dungeons at least not that I've seen
like what nothing that Nails it down
like this is gonna have dungeons but I
think the underground is pretty much
confirmed by this point the the Goblins
seem to be mining at least yeah that's a
goblin you can see from the Bighorn so
because they have big horns now suddenly
this whole Stone structure might even be
a Talus since we have seen natalysis can
be used like as transportation for some
enemies now which is pretty cool
but yeah it's it's it's mining something
not sure why but it it's very
interesting uh next one very very
interesting which might look familiar
for people who've played uh let me check
my notes
either the original Zelda Minish Cap or
Phantom Hourglass because that's the oh
those are the only games why this enemy
appears in and I'm pretty sure that's
the same enemy that this has to be glioc
which is a classic classic Zelda enemy
so gliox sometimes they have two heads
sometimes just one uh I I'm pretty sure
the one in Minish Cap only has one uh
and the one in Phantom Hourglass has two
or three oh yeah two two-headed dragon
glioc so but uh but this one has has
three and they're flaming flaming heads
so that is that is just a straight up
dragon and it looks huge like a proper
Overworld boss maybe or it's it's
blocking something on the other side of
the bridge which is amazing it looks it
looks really cool uh yeah next shot we
see purse Tech Lab uh we see another one
of those spirals they seem to be pretty
close to civilizations as well and again
might just be fast travel points at this
point I'm starting to think that might
be the case but I'm not 100 sure uh
looks like ateno Village itself looks
fine we can see lights burning so it
might just be fine which means we still
have our house we can still use our
house our house is safe
uh by the way they did provide
screenshots which I will sometimes be
using instead of actual footage I will
just show the screenshot
because the screenshots from the press
kit are way better quality they don't
include all the shots but they look way
better it almost looks like a next-gen
game I'm not sure if that's actually how
the game is going to look like because
YouTube compression does do a number on
these especially these darker shots that
can be uh yeah pretty detrimental to to
the footage itself next we see the blood
moon uh link standing looking at the
blood moon uh nice to see that the blood
moon is back because that's like the
source of ganon's power or at least in
in breath of the wild it was like
Calamity ganon's power it amplifies his
magic then we see Hyrule castle and I'm
not too sure but the side of it looks
like all covered in Malice we see
projectiles being fired from what looks
like from the blood moon might have
might not actually be originating from
the blood moon itself in fact it doesn't
look to be because the arch doesn't
really match looks very similar to the
shot from the the original game from
breath of the Wild
where he takes over the Guardians I
think this malice is just gonna spread
all across high road it's going to take
over some monsters which may explain why
some of the creatures we've seen like
the lizophos have like glowing Embers of
malice on their bodies uh we see another
one of the Spiral thingies uh this looks
to be close to this this is the great
plateau and this is like on the edge of
the uh of the desert uh this shot is
quite interesting I'm not too sure if I
think this is Ganondorf I can also kind
of see a Lino type shape I don't know if
you can see it maybe it's just me but
could also just be Ganondorf it's it's
very hard to see maybe this is what sets
off the explosion and all the malice
starts going everywhere we see some sort
of big glowing Boulder which I guess has
to be somewhere around Death Mountain
either that or it's a floating island
that has oh actually maybe it's a giant
creature that could also be it does move
in kind of a weird way but it seems to
be crashing down so it's either close to
Death Mountain and something is being
moved there like something huge is being
moved there or this like we know that
some of the islands have different
climates we've seen we've seen snowy
Islands so maybe there's like lava
Islands too this shot is pretty much the
same shot from the second teaser where
we see the the tower starting to
collapse around the around the castle
next one great plateau again
um
not much to see here one of those
glowing drawings again on the side of
one of the mountains oh yeah actually I
had to see this is why it's a good thing
to just improvise it this time because
yeah we can actually see those Blobs of
malice hitting enemies so that's how
they're gonna get infected and even
become even more strong and more
dangerous very reminiscent of that
cutscene where the blood moon first
appears okay but here is where we get to
something that's gonna as people know
I'm a big horror guy I love this the the
scary side of Zelda and uh that is a
read Ed that is definitely a readout it
has to be right zombie-esque flesh which
just stops and it becomes a spine and uh
like the bottom part of his uh rib cage
a vertical mouth like a slit mouth which
is really creepy I've never thought
about doing that to a read ad the
glowing eyes yeah I mean this is
Nightmare fuel I cannot wait to
encounter this kind of stuff inside
caves really creepy I'm so happy to see
red ads we see a new type of pig enemy
seems like a bit like a a mix between a
normal vocabula and a hinox like
somewhere in between a bit more a bit
bigger big more a bit more Burly so we
see link riding around in the field here
we can see that storm again alas it's
not like I I foretold in my video it's
not actually enveloping it is like right
above hebra Peak it seems so I was right
about the location but it's not actually
enveloping the mountain itself it seems
to be hovering above it which I don't
know if that has any ramifications for
the mountain itself or that air general
area maybe there's just an island hidden
inside the eye of that storm but yeah
that we finally see that storm actually
and not not just on the on the artwork
but we actually see it in the trailer
itself pretty cool uh something is
happening here something is coming out
of the ground which we never get to see
it's a very short shot actually this is
the first time I I see this shot because
it's so it's so fast you don't really
see what's going on here but these seem
to be dust clouds because they are like
morphing and moving so something is
coming out of the ground might be a
dungeon or this game's equivalent of a
shrine which may be like bigger shrines
not too sure uh then we get to see this
which is weird because these are
Guardian type arms and as we knew before
Guardians don't really seem to be a
thing anymore so if I had to guess this
might be connected to like Pura or
Robbie and this might be like the
upgrade station where link can you know
maybe upgrade his powers or something
else because he he doesn't seem to it
looks like the way he's standing there
and those those uh because also in the
next shot like there's a little grabby
hands on doing their thing it seems like
more like Whimsical I don't think this
is supposed to be like an actual
dangerous moment this might just be
something that plays whenever he
upgrades something or they can enhance
his weapons or something along those
lines which may may be a hint that Pura
and Robbie will still be a thing and
they will still help link with their
technology and stuff because obviously
they still have technology it's just
that the regular Guardians don't seem to
be roaming around anymore or at least we
haven't seen it uh next shot we see
another one of those more Burly type of
piggies fat Larry we see a hinox or
hinox whatever you want to call it it's
got a like a gem around its neck not
sure why if that's like a treasure or if
it's just for Aesthetics or but more
interestingly uh we see a cave type of
area and I hope this is like
confirmation that this is gonna feature
like underground stuff although it is a
bit bright so it might just be an out
Cove somewhere but I'm hoping this is
underground that would be pretty cool
but yeah link is running away from it
nothing like he's got some spiky thing
on his head which they didn't have in
the in the base game I'm pretty sure uh
next shot we can see Satori Mountain we
can see some of the islands everywhere
I'm not going to get into the islands
too much because we've we know they're
up there and we just see keep seeing new
clusters of them so they there there's a
lot of them uh actually I'm surprised
how little focused this trailer this
trailer really seems to focus on the on
the ground for a change I'm pretty sure
this is just one of those glowing
drawings uh but you're like really up
close you're like right on top of it so
it just looks like random lines and
stuff but if you would zoom out it would
show the the picture which we still
don't know what they are for and what
their purpose is but it's pretty cool
next shot more flying enemies and we see
the coblins riding these enemies and uh
one thing to note he has one of those
like Stone axes which we saw link use or
at least he has it on his back in the
previous teaser so I guess that's where
he got it from just it's just one of
those primitive weapons that they tend
to carry you know usually they have like
dragon bone clubs and they've reached
the Stone Age
you might notice this is typho ruins
without the black smoke around it uh if
you remember in breath of the wild when
you beat typho ruins the The Fog the
black fog did not disappear it just
stayed there regardless not sure why
it's subtly gone but it is so cool cool
cool cool okay next shot we got some
moblins with their little fancy new hats
nothing too special about that I think
this might be uh either just a rock
formation or it's an enemy camp because
I do see some scaffolding up here now
this shot is pretty interesting uh one
thing that's also interesting is that
they have a screenshot of this creature
but it's mirrored so it's a it's not
actually from this trailer it's
different not sure why but as you can
see it's a giant robot made of Cubes
when it slams onto the ground you can
even see the cubes kind of dislocating
so it's being held together what by this
like green energy that you can see uh
same green type of green energy that we
saw coiling through those robot
creatures from the second teaser so I
guess it's based on the same principle
in in fact the the material looks very
similar too and this is on one of the
floating islands so I guess this new
technology is associated with this Sky
civilization next shot we have Ganondorf
looks like an Agony and is like
struggling to pump out some malice like
the malice seems like it's ready to
burst out of his chest I guess this is
right before he attacks link or he
breaks free because the eyes are not
glowing yet so this is his corpse
Reawakening the hand is already gone the
hand that was clutching onto his chest
is already gone at this stage but and
then of course the the eyes are gonna
light up which we will see in a moment
too we see Hiro Castle then we see this
part which I cannot believe I was
actually kind of sort of correct two
years ago which is like he seems to be
Conjuring up some sort of cave-in or
earthquake because you can see all the
dust clouds you can see debris starting
to fall down the platform has changed
significantly because I'm pretty sure
this is supposed to be the same platform
that we saw in the first teaser but in
the first season it looked more like a
natural rock formation which kind of was
carved out to look like like a circle or
pedestal but this one is just straight
up man-made blocks with symbols on them
or at least decorations we we don't
really see the symbols in fact the the
new scripture that we've seen on the
mural and stuff doesn't seem to show up
in this teaser at all so next we have
this shot which is almost exactly the
same as the one from the first teaser so
I'm sure this is the same shot just
reworked next shot is link looking
majestically over the landscape which
ties into that next shot as for the
landscape itself we can see a floating
block so not all the islands are like
more like a natural rock formation as if
they've been like torn from the ground
some of them have you can see it with
those in the distance too they are much
more blocky and and man-made compared to
the other ones like aside from the
antennas they kind of look like skyloft
like just a piece of Earth we see
another one of those towers with the
spotlights right here so there seems to
be quite a lot of them I think we've
counted four or five at least now so I
do think these will probably be this
game's equivalent of the shika Towers
the shika towers are obviously gone so
there has to be a replacement which is
going to be this they don't seem to be
as big as the shika Towers but I'm
starting to think that they are the same
basic concept also you can probably tell
my voice is a very very rough right now
so sorry for that I've been talking a
lot with like after the stream ended I
just kept on talking and talking and
talking with Dr Wily and Nintendo black
crisis here we get another skydiving
shot which is pretty cool we see the
vials again uh up close still no idea
what they do but they're there the
camera pans around and we see the
landscape again not that much to see
except well actually the the this Tower
looks pretty big it actually might be a
lot bigger than it looks on on some in
some of the other footage next shot we
see one of those drawings on the floor
we see one of those Towers again uh they
seem to have a sort of horn structure on
top like I said but in this one you can
see it a lot better there's some sort of
anime Camp because again you can see the
scaffolding now this one's pretty
interesting you can see this is like a
homing missile because he shoots it in a
different direction and it just Auto
targets the enemy so heat-seeking
missiles powered by this green energy as
you can see because right before he
charges it up the green energy is being
gathered around it so here we have Tony
Hawk Pro Skater link 2. of course we
could already Shield surf but now we can
Shield grind on rail which is pretty
cool I like it this is clearly around
the Death Mountain area you can even see
the Springs down there you can see some
Minecarts and this weird new rock thing
which I have no idea what it is it looks
very weird almost like an alien meteor
or something not sure if the red part is
malice it doesn't it doesn't really look
like malice malice is usually more
blackish like a mix between black and
red and glows a lot more and usually has
Embers floating around it and all that
kind of stuff so not sure what it is but
it looks weird if you look closely you
can see that this Goblin actually has
two horns it's like a fork sticking out
so it's not just that they have longer
horns they also have differently
different shaped horns I'm not sure if
that's uh unique to the blue ones maybe
these two blue ones at least have the
forked horn so we can also see a green
disc laying here and I'm already pretty
sure what this is uh but we'll we'll get
to that in in a moment here we have the
bane of our existence which I'm pretty
sure this is a motion control puzzle I
mean it was to be expected that there
would be at least some motion control
nonsense in here again now this one
definitely seems to hint at underground
stuff the one with the high knocks was
still a bit too bright for me to be uh
to conclude that it was underground like
I said it could have been an outgo for
something but this one we have the
Luminous Stones which were also in the
first teaser a lot they also seem to be
in a quantity that we normally didn't
see on the surface in breath of the wild
so I'd say this is a pretty solid
confirmation that there will be
underground stuff it's not just gonna be
this guy which is something a lot of us
been have been talking about since the
beginning and now that we know that the
sky is going to be a big thing we kind
of started well maybe underground is
actually just what that one cut scene
but it looks like that's not the case
there will be underground stuff too yeah
we see a Talus with a Lumina Stone on it
I think those were in breath of the wild
so that's nothing new
uh the weapon is though the link is
using some sort of new weapon it's a
zonai dragon head again so whatever this
technology is it's it's tied to the
dragons and maybe the zonai but it's a
similar concept a similar concept as
that flamethrower that we saw in the in
the second teaser also you'll notice
that the the symbol on the back of it as
he turns around after he uh does the
attack you can see that symbol it's the
same one that we saw on those dragons or
well I don't know if they're dragons but
they have dragon-esque features but
those Golem thingies and actually now
that I view it more closely we do have
the script they're a script in in this
teaser it's on the side here and the
fact that this is clearly one of those
zonai dragon heads like we saw so many
of on on the surface of breath of the
wild like these forgotten relics of the
zonai to me kind of confirms that this
script is probably tied to this tribe
maybe some of you will think like duh
it's it's a new script we know zonai
stuff is going to be in the game we have
dragons everywhere so but the mural we
saw in the last teaser was not exactly
it didn't really look Zone I made it
didn't have that recognizable style of
them so we weren't actually sure if this
new script is tied to the zonai or if
it's something completely new like a
different civilization living up in the
sky somewhere who invented this
scripture but for me this is a very
strong hint that this is a technology
tied to the zonai with their script on
it and there's gonna be all kinds of
variations of these types of weapons
like we saw the flamethrower and now we
have this thing now here's a very
interesting one uh is it hylia is it
someone else is it a Zona I have no idea
they just this is again very different
because the hand thingy that we saw is
green and it has like this ethereal look
to it this just looks like a normal
person a pretty pale looking person
actually but of course they don't show
the face so we have no idea so they are
extending a hand to to what I presume to
be link right after he gets the bracelet
and now that I think about it it could
also be a previous incarnation of a
princess who once fought Ganondorf you
know the one we saw on the tapestry from
10 000 years ago or something either way
someone is extending their aid to link
and is probably also the one who gave
the bracelet to him my guess is that
this is probably right after he got
attacked and receives the bracelet and
he wakes up you know this might be the
first appearance of this being whoever
it is who's like hey you had a rough
night here let me get you back on your
feet and let's let's get going you you
have a demon king to fight I guess this
shot is also pretty early on because
he's looking at the arm like he's seeing
the bracelet for the first time or
starting to understand what it is or
what it can do so I would say it's
probably somewhere at the beginning okay
so here is where it gets interesting so
he's fishing up a wheel with uh first of
all this is clearly the this game's
equivalent of magnesis which shows that
link still has powers that are very
similar if not identical it's just if
this time it's not coming from the Chica
slate it's the new bracelet uh thingy
that he that he uses so he's lifting
this object out of a swamp and in the
next shot you can immediately see what
this is it's it's a wheel uh they're
identical and uh you will see in in
Rapid succession from this point on is
every time you will see one of those
parts you will also see this greenish
goo on it which attaches to something so
it looks like we're gonna be building
our own vehicles uh you'll be puzzling
them together you can mend them together
with this uh this whatever it is green
energy goo Spirit goo because the rest
of the car is just wood it's just some
planks put together very crudely but the
the other parts are clearly of that same
type of technology that we see that
we've seen so many times the Golem thing
is probably also that big Cube monster
thing the cube robot thing so it looks
like we'll be assembling our own
Vehicles which I mean that is such a
cool concept and nobody would have
guessed this no theorists out there was
like What if we can build our own
Vehicles so that just goes to show how
Nintendo always comes up with things we
didn't know we wanted but I I really
like the idea on the side of the Dragon
we can see that same symbol once again
that we saw on the other Dragon weapon
and on the on the Golem the little
broomstick I'm just gonna call it a
broomstick and in the next few shots we
get the confirmation that this is what's
what's happening because here again we
see the group The the energy glue and he
made a balloon out of it so another way
to Traverse this guy we have a glider
now we have a balloon and uh I'm sure
we're gonna see another one right after
this one yeah it's the quad quadcopter
the quad drone so these seem to be Parts
he can just randomly find everywhere
either on the Overworld or maybe on some
of the islands and you can just stitch
them together and just create your own
Vehicles your own ways of transportation
so these the last one was a wheel these
are like the uh the like propellers and
you can just attach them to something uh
because this metal part doesn't look
like it's the same material even so I
guess you can just find something like a
like a platform or a slab and then glue
these things on it and just there you go
you're flying a quadcopter now uh so we
see the Death Star nothing too special
actually I have no idea what it is it's
it's some dome in the in the sky we
already saw a cube a floating cube so
hey let's use all the Primitives right
so we see those stacked islands in the
distance we see more Islands Islands
Islands Islands the only thing that
really stands out which we haven't seen
before are these weird streams they look
yeah they look like they are extending
all the way to the bottom not sure what
they are maybe once you've been on an
island you can activate some sort of
fast travel thing because that that's
one thing about the gameplay Loop of
Tears of the Kingdom that have been
pondering I've been wondering about is
like once you have reached one of these
islands that's going to be a challenge
of course each island is at different
altitudes so you will have to get to a
certain point in the sky find a way to
get there I should say and then once you
do you don't want to do that whole thing
again you don't want to have to go from
the the surface to the sky every time by
using all these Methods at some point
once you've visited one of these islands
you I would assume there's like a way to
get back there quickly so maybe that's
what these streams are I'm not sure but
we definitely haven't seen this before
next we have a beautiful shot of central
Hyrule once again uh some sort of Blocky
structure standing in the middle of the
field which was not there in breath of
the wild another one of those Towers
here and here right at the end of the
shot we can see an object falling down
with a green trail behind it which I'm
pretty sure is that like Sky debris that
we've seen literally around Hyrule in
other teasers even in the second teaser
we already saw some of it of course back
then we didn't know what it was or what
it was for but in the last season we saw
him writing one of those pieces of
debris up so I think that's just what
this is and then the logo appears which
we already saw in the previous teaser so
yeah not much to say about that but then
oh no there's more so this is actually a
pretty interesting shot because it looks
like a link is going to be attacked
twice because you can see his arm is
already scarred there's already malice
on the on the master sword but it's not
broke it's not like in the state yet
that we've seen in the delay
announcement footage so it is covered in
Malice but it's not like rotten away
just yet but Link's arm already looks
pretty screwed up so it seems like
Ganondorf will give him a double whammy
then the malice bursts out we can say
link looking kind of frustrated he's
like oh man not again and whatever
happens next uh in the next shot Link's
arm looks terrible here you can really
see the damage it did to his to his arm
it's it looks it looks so messed up I
did not expect them to make it look this
bad because in the earlier footage it
looks more like a tattoo almost you know
I guess by this point the master sword
is already broken uh it's already almost
completely gone because he immediately
drops it like without a hesitation he's
just like nope don't need that anymore
and the reason why is well that's what
we're gonna see in the next shot he
Dives straight after Zelda what's
interesting is that in this shot it
looks like he's gonna make it like he's
probably if he just drops with her he
can somehow grab her hand and I don't
know maybe
I don't know somehow they will make it
back and of course this is older footage
but in the previous teasers the picture
is very different we see Zelda falling
into the abyss so we know she's gonna
fall and we also have a shot where the
green arm uh thingy is grabbing onto
Link's arm so maybe the green arm grabs
link saves his life but it's too late
for Zelda I guess we get the
confirmation that no this game is not
delayed and then it's done actually I
just got a notification that I have a
copyright claim on the on the Stream
it's so frustrating there's always that
one game always that one game that uses
copyrighted music anyway yeah that's the
whole trailer okay so I actually uh went
back and listened to all the audio uh
once more uh I will get into the voices
in a moment but I just wanted to quickly
say
in this shot where you can see that the
goblin mining that seems to be on the
ground for sure because uh the way to
pickaxe like the sound it makes it
sounds very Hollow it sounds KV not like
uh it wouldn't sound like that uh I'll
play it for you
the echo definitely seems to hint at
something on the ground it wouldn't
sound like this out in the open and if
this is underground that means that
there's going to be all kinds of weird
vegetation like I said this uh weird
tree thing with the bulb at the at the
bottom it looks like an underground like
an underworld I should say a little bit
like the one in Skyward Sword in the
Ancient Cistern you know which might
also explain these Spirits because if
this is like an underground like a
mirror reflection of Hyrule or somewhere
deep below Hyrule where the malice is
where the underworld lies it would
explain why these Spirits might be here
if it's a dark underworld obviously
normal human beings wouldn't be able to
survive survive here which is also what
happened in Twilight Princess they turn
into Spirits because they mingle with
the dark so I think that might be the
reason why we see these Flames here
anyway let's get into the voices rise
rise my servants
sweep over Hyrule eliminate this Kingdom
and her allies
leave no survivors
so the stuff Ganondorf says it's nothing
too special he's summoning his minions
uh what is very dark is he's like leave
no survivors which is he does not care
anymore he's not like oh I'm gonna rule
this Kingdom or no he doesn't care
anymore he just wants it and everyone
else in it that what's also interesting
is he mentions this Kingdom and its
allies destroy this Kingdom and its
allies which I think is referring to the
people in the sky which is a separate
Kingdom Allied to Hyrule so he's not
just hell-bent on destroying Hyrule but
everything like everyone who who
supports Hyrule in any way shape or form
which also ties into what Zelda says at
the end uh she says like lend lend him
your strength please lend him your power
him referring to link and uh
she seems to be addressing someone else
some other entity some other race or
being probably the same people who
granted him the the bracelet zonai
whatever you want to call them I don't
know what they are yet we'll see but
these are obviously allies to Hyrule
because they are helping him they are
lending their strength to link so
Ganondorf also has it out for them too
he is out to kill everyone which is so
dark I love it so yeah overall
Impressions uh this was a amazing
trailer there's so much more I want to
talk about I can already see like 10
little things in the distance where I'm
like oh what's that what's that I want
to keep analyzing them uh I will have a
video up like a proper video soon
because this don't count this as a
monster maze video like your typical
monster maze video because it's it's
going to be very very crude I haven't
edited it yet
I'm still recording so I'm not sure how
it will turn out but it's not going to
have like uh high production because I
have to finish this up before the the
sun comes up here but yeah I will have
something up very soon and I will I will
just pick some stuff that I really want
to talk about we have all these new
pieces now and I want to turn it into a
story and make a proper video out of it
with some decent editing but yeah thank
you all so much for uh for for for
turning up
um I'm going to save the patreon stuff
and the channel member stuff for the uh
like proper video because there were
also a couple of people who joined as a
new member during the stream so I hope
you guys understand uh you will get your
shout out you will get your uh thanks
um I'm always super grateful that is
there's no question about that I'm
always so humbled whenever I see someone
joining me or joining my channel I
should say or
joining my patreon it's it's
heartwarming I I there's no other way to
to say it super super grateful anyway
that is all for now I'm going to uh get
to the edit
so future me uh take it from here
bye bye